hey guys how's it going matt here uh
just wanted to talk a little bit about
my game engine and some updates on it
i've made some more decisions on how i'm
gonna handle things in the future so i
just wanted to fill you all in because
uh
yeah how else you're gonna know right
all right so i uh
okay i had to change this camera angle
because i had my camera in a different
spot than my mic and it was like it was
it was kind of throwing me off but okay
so uh previously i said i was making
uh future updates private
and
my reasoning for that is most was mostly
because like i'm testing a lot of stuff
and i just don't want to be pushing
every little thing i'm testing to the
public one especially if it's like
i find out in the future it's bad
practice or it doesn't work right and
people are maybe following my ideas and
implementing it on their own and then
they're gonna break stuff you blame me
etc etc
i just didn't want to deal with that
whole
nightmare
of
potential stuff so
uh
basically
i started working on it privately and
i've been working on it some off and on
and trying to get updates going and i
think i'm just gonna i am gonna
continue updating the one
the public one but i think i'm gonna
make development of it private
and once like i'm done developing a new
feature and i'm happy with it i think it
works correctly
then i'll put it on the main branch
or the main repo rather
and basically put it as like a release
so that way i'm not going to have like
all the day-to-day little tweaks going
on on the main repo and this should also
keep the commit
history and everything small so if you
clone it it doesn't take four days to
clone
and i i also need to clean up the
history so that only the tags remain and
i basically don't want it to be
something where if you clone the project
just natively you can
you can there's a way to clone things of
course without
taking grabbing all the history but
normally when you just clone things you
also grab all the commit history of all
the branches and it could be like this
massive
massive cl uh
file size
for your the folder that is your project
or is the project you're downloading
and yeah i didn't really well i wasn't
really happy with that i don't want you
to have to download four gigs of data to
get like 100 megabytes of actual stuff
that you're going to use that's just
that's just kind of annoying
so
yeah that's that's really kind of uh
another
whole thought process in the whole thing
and of course this is all
a benefit to anyone that follows the
stuff so i hope you like the change you
can't imagine why you would dislike it
but you know some people are weird and
are like oh how dare you help me i just
like you know i can't control people
uh but
i think it's the right thing to do here
i hope that makes sense and
it took me a while to come to this
conclusion
okay so on the latest version i have out
there you know there's a lot of good
stuff going for it the animations work
there's generally a lot of stuff working
but it's not anything you can't figure
out on your own if you're following
something like the learn help opengl
which is where i learned most of this so
huge shout out to them but i've also
added in a lot of my own custom stuff
too
uh but uh you know a lot of that stuff
is just uh
the stuff on the learn opengl is
you know stuff you need to know if
you're going to be doing graphics so a
very great place to learn and i think a
lot of people have kind of started game
engines for it so in a way i'm just kind
of yet another game engine so to me
the only thing special about it is the
the parts that i've personally
implemented and custom parts i've i've
made without following tutorials i
always feel like when i'm following a
tutorial the thing i'm doing is not as
special
i don't know if you guys feel like that
too but it still doesn't
detract from the point that you're still
learning uh which is which is important
and it's like it's like taking a free
course basically which is awesome you
can't beat that courses are expensive
alright so the way this currently is i
have future development down here it
says no longer maintained future
development let's move to a private
space access given to supporters and
that's true i'm still going to kee i'm
going to change this a little bit so i'm
going to make the development
i don't know how exactly i'm going to do
this but here's what i'm thinking you
guys can let me down know down below
what you think makes the most sense if
you want
or if you're interested but at some
point like once this gets to a level
where i start adding a lot of other
renders and it becomes like
realistically usable for people to
actually like make games and projects
with which it yeah in my opinion it sort
of is now but there's better choices
like unreal or unity or godot or there's
a million others are further along than
mine
so it does it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense to use this if you're serious
about your project this is more like
just a play around thing that's my
opinion maybe you think differently
that's that's fine but yeah unreal and
unity are real if you want more
uh features that are like more worked
out and done uh you would use one of
those obviously right that's i don't
even need to say that's just kind of an
obvious thing so i don't expect people
to realistically be using this for games
uh development although i
you know i plan to that's my whole plan
but and i want to make it public there's
no reason to like have this all hidden
because i do want like people to be able
to help if they want to
and see the code if they want to
but i don't want to have like my
personal the game i'm working on files
in here which are kind of in here like
they're this example project
is uh you know it's all my own stuff of
implementing or using my library so
that was starting to include stuff that
was like
a unique game of my own decision type
stuff and i don't want to i don't want
to have that in here so i'm going to
keep the one that's here that's fine it
can stay here but i need to keep that
separate and that's part of the
development thing too
so eventually
if things keep going well or things
scale up and go well i do want to like
hire some other developers to help me
work on this stuff because it's a lot
for one person and sometimes i'm just
stuck for days not knowing really what
to do
or how to fix a certain thing it just
happens when you're a programmer
sometimes i i generally eventually
figure it out and of course feel a bit
foolish for overlooking uh
one little thing or something but hey it
happens
and that's gonna happen privately rather
than publicly now which i feel a lot
more comfortable with
and that can also happen you know with
the team and
whoever i'm working with and that sort
of thing
hopefully in the future don't it's not
like that currently i'd love to find
other people to work with but it's
almost impossible
uh so i've noticed not i don't want to
like complain about that or anything
it's just it just is what it is i don't
know that's maybe a topic for another
video or something
but i'm kind of curious do other
programmers that are working on stuff
have like an almost impossible time
finding other people to work with i do
and i'm i even have a channel where i
can like shout it out and say come join
me and i still can't get people to come
join me uh in actually helping uh you
know that's
that's neither here nor there
um
so
that's
that really puts a damper on me hiring
people too
and i guess you know now let's come up i
should probably say it because i feel
like if i hire somebody
they're probably not even going to know
how to help me basically anyway
i don't that makes a whole lot of sense
but i've i have yet to run into a single
person a single one not a single one has
come up that has knew how to help with
any of this stuff
uh so far and i've live streamed a ton
of it and stuff and just it just doesn't
happen they're just not out there or
they're incredibly it's incredibly rare
to find people
that actually know
kind of how to do this stuff and what to
do next it is so so rare so when you
find someone you should probably like
treasure them i i had one at one point
and i think i messed it up because uh he
won't even answer me anymore
uh sorry eric i don't i don't know what
i did or maybe you're in a funk and
don't
know what's going on with things but uh
i loved it when we're working together
on stuff and i miss you but
that's all i can say and i guess i gotta
say it publicly because as far as i know
he doesn't read my messages or anything
uh
i don't know why i do not know why but i
didn't know why i would try to fix it
but it's just weird to me
so
i i can't blame him or anyone
but that just happens i guess uh or
maybe he was too intimidated by the
whole thing i i like i said i don't know
he wouldn't answer he just kind of went
full ghost which
uh usually is a sign that you should
never talk to that person again
that's just my personal opinion but if
someone goes to you you give them like
one chance or two chances to answer like
hey what's going on what happened and if
they don't answer that then it's like
all right i get it
there's a lot of other people in the
world a lot of other fish in the sea
so
yeah so that's the plans hopefully i can
find some help with the future
development uh especially if i can
figure out a proper budget with this
being an unfunded project it's very hard
i tried to open some funding with the
sponsor thing but there's been uh no
interest in that as of yet
hopefully someone will it would mean a
lot maybe if you got extra funds to
throw at it even for a month or two it
would mean a ton it's definitely going
to go towards the development of the
project and these projects that i work
on
but uh
you know there's a famous saying that
says as an artist you don't really get
to choose if you're successful or not
you basically just gotta show up and do
the work and that's literally all you
can do is just show up and do the work
and whether it's successful or not has
nothing to do with you totally up to the
people that perceive it and what happens
to most artists at least in the past
maybe not maybe not in these days with
more ways to share but
yeah in the past basically
people
work as an artist their whole life you
could probably find examples of this if
you just google this sort of
quote
or this sort of instance
people work their whole lives writing
books drawing
whatever they do painting and then it's
you know they have no success they're
poor their entire life and then when
they die
they get rich which is like totally
useless because they're dead it's
hilarious but it's just the life of in
general an artist and i do consider
myself more of an artist
than a traditional blue or white colored
worker so that's just the way i've kind
of always been
but uh
yeah i know a lot of rambling here
but i feel like this is stuff i need to
get out so hopefully you'll find it
interesting
and if you made it this far i guess you
probably do so thanks thanks for your
interest it does mean a lot
so yeah i think the development files
and development iterations that are more
small and day-to-day yeah going to be
for the higher-end supporters that also
does include
uh like me
talking to you more about this stuff so
if you have more questions about
development if you're trying to learn
and figure out like why i would do
something this way
that's also going to be the place for
that so i want to schedule like a a
bi-weekly or monthly meet up for all the
source supporters
to do that sort of thing and it can be
like tutoring whatever you want spend an
hour or two just like hashing out things
uh that would be cool i think that would
be a nice benefit that some people want
like people have reached out to me and
said hey i want to be tutored and i'm
like i have a i have i literally have a
tier for that
so rather than like send me an email
trying to offer me money just sign up
for the tier and we'll do it but that i
don't know there's some kind of
people are weird i i really don't get
people or maybe they don't get me and
that's why i don't get them
so i'm trying i don't know that's why
i'm gonna put out this video i think
because
i get it like people are
everyone's different and
apparently i'm very hard to understand
because
my ways are a bit scattered and i change
things frequently and i have ideas about
things and you know
and i'm kind of as i mentioned last
video going through a new phase of my
life where i'm really trying to
straighten out my mentality i've had
this
this uh mindset
that's been
kind of plaguing me for a long time and
i'm actually very surprised to find some
success on this channel
while i had that mindset
and it was i don't know how to explain
it but it was it was sort of like a very
overly critical and pessimistic kind of
mindset that i had to be very careful
with and i think uh there was definitely
some videos in the past that i quickly
took down when i realized oh man i was i
was that guy i didn't want to be in that
video kind of thing
so i'm trying to like get rid of that
guy not like 100 altogether because i do
need the critical side of me but i don't
need to like
let it send me into a
weird rage that drives people away i
need to like find a way to make it
useful so there's a lot more to it than
that but that's like the overarching
uh
version of it i don't know if anyone
else has that sort of problem but i
don't think i'm totally unique to that
sort of problem
so
yeah is there anything else i wanted to
mention let me think here
yeah i guess that's it for now i could
probably go on but i don't want to make
this super long just look forward to
seeing some updates on this main repo
when i have them ready i'll probably
make a little just documentation changes
here on some of this front end but i've
got i've got a lot of work to do and
it's really hard to get all these
straight out properly like i'm trying to
get the ecs
worked out and i'm also thinking maybe i
don't need an ecs entirely because
implementing it really like gutted
the whole
system i had going on before
and it was just making it more difficult
my opinion
uh maybe it won't do that after it's
better implemented but it's not
something that's probably going to be
out anytime soon
so we'll see i've got to give it a few
more tries try a few more things
recently i've been working more on the
render graph and getting more
render features working properly
and then once most of that's done i'll
probably uh go on to the next feature
but yeah i really want to get like
shadows stenciling hdr stuff a lot of
this stuff basically
worked out but uh
it's a lot harder than it seems there's
there's some days where i think today's
the day i'm going to get this finished
and it's it usually doesn't go that way
in the long run there's there have been
occasions when that has worked out when
i like it has been
like that but
motivation is tricky
especially for me i think it's going to
get better now i'm working on my mindset
a lot
and keeping that in mind but
really i'm just going to try to keep
putting in the work because i've also
noticed that motivation doesn't just
strike well sometimes it does for me
sometimes it does sometimes i just wake
up one day and motivation strikes i'm
doing this today i'm giving it my best
shot and i hope it works sometimes that
happens to me but
i've also noticed that that simply does
not happen if i'm not trying
really hard previous days where i'm not
so motivated that happens kind of
randomly on a day
after i've been non-motivated working i
don't know if that makes sense but uh to
say it a different way like say
on day one of some set on some week i'll
work really hard and be like frustrated
the whole day and feel like i get
nothing done on day two it might be
similar then on day three something
clicks and suddenly i realize oh today's
the day i know how to i understand how
to do this all of a sudden and
like that'll be the day where i feel
like motivation strikes but that
wouldn't have happened if it weren't for
the two days of frustration i don't that
makes sense let me know what you guys
think but that literally does happen to
me
sometimes and it doesn't just happen out
of the blue that's that's all i'm saying
so you got to put in those frustrating
days i think that's an important lesson
for any of you uh lifelong coders or
someone that's really trying to work at
things and also that's really important
if you're a boss or leading some code
project is to know that
you basically
don't see you won't always see results
from every programmer every day or maybe
well maybe you see little stuff but as
long as they're working hard
like you need to realize that one day
they're going to have these click days
where things like really
get get done and maybe not everyone's
like that maybe people are better
programmers than me and
can actually like knock stuff out really
well every day
more power to you if you can
but that's not most people i know i've
never personally met anyone like that
maybe maybe like john carmax like that
or something i'm not really sure he
probably is but he's had
uh we'll say
probably 30 more years of experience
than i so that kind of makes sense
uh yeah
you know programmers that have been
doing it forever they can of course
knock stuff out very quick but uh that's
that's kind of different you definitely
got to build up to that you can't expect
to do that on your first few years of
coding or anything like that that's all
i'm saying
all right well that's it if you don't
mind if you could go to this repo just
uh
you know i'll leave it down below and
give it a star consider sponsoring or
signing up on patreon or hitting the
youtube stuff it really does help a lot
keeping my coding projects going and
this channel going
and
yeah we'll go from there appreciate you
guys take care of yourselves and keep
coding